Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Cersei Valonqar prophecy
video. There's evidence for a couple different
people being the valonqar, so I will explain
what the prophecy is and who I think it is.
Just careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far. There is a new
round of the Game of Thrones giveaway going
on now;
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video, it's for
an HBO now gift certificate. be sure to click
that bell to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything during the break.
So as a child Cersei visited Maggie the frog
and asked her three questions.
One of those answers was the prophecy of the
Valonqar, but the TV show only showed part of that.
Cersei: "Tell me my future or I'll have your two boring eyes gouged out of your head."
Maggie: "Oh yes. You'll be queen. For a time.
"Then comes another. Younger. More beautiful. To cast you down and take all you hold dear."
Cersei: "Will the king and I have children?"
Maggie: "The king will have 20 children. And you will have 3."
Cersei: "That doesn't make sense."
Maggie: "Gold will be their crowns.
"Gold, their shrouds."
So you can see how the TV show wanted
to highlight how Cersei would lose all her
children and how another younger more beautiful
person would come along to take her throne,
talking about Margaery Tyrell. But another
part of Maggie's prophecy, the Valonqar, was
left out.
Probably because they wanted to do it later
on the show and it didn't really have anything
to do with what was happening during season
five. So the full prophecy goes like this: Cersei
asks her, "Will the King and I have children?"
and Maggie answers, "Oh aye, 6 and 10 for him,"
talking about all of Robert's bastards, he had
a lot of children, "three for you," talking about
Cersei's children, "gold shall be their crowns
and gold shall be their shrouds." Talking about
how they wind up dying.
Then she goes on and says, "And when your tears
have drowned you, the Valonqar shall wrap his
hands about your pale white throat and choke
the life from you."
So Valonqar is High Valyrian for younger brother,
so a lot of people read this
and they say okay her younger brother Tyrion
is going to kill her eventually, because of scenes like this:
Tyrion: "I will hurt you for this. The day would come when you think you're
safe and happy and your joy will turn to ash
your mouth.
You know, the debt is paid.
So just taken at face value Tyrion has always
been the leading candidate for the Valonqar
he is their younger brother Jaime and Cersei
are twins, but what is been changing in the
last couple of seasons on the TV show Jaime
has slowly been becoming a good person even
though he is still very much connected to
Cersei like it seems like he might break from
her influence he feels like he loves her.
He has a duty to her, but his heart is pulled
to Brienne her good influence has slowly been
inspiring him to do better and better things
he's trying to do good.
But Godfather style Cersei's been pulling
him back in and now that she is Queen she
is more powerful than ever.
So even though were getting ready for all
out war in the seven kingdoms between the
forces of the crown Cersei Daenerys's forces
and Jon Snow's forces, there's still a lot
of Jaime when he was at Riverrun it's starting
to slowly realize that this is all madness.
So when you rewatch the Riverrun scenes you
can see that he could've just wrote in with
his soldiers killed everyone and taken the
castle that he actually tried to reason with
everyone he tried to reason with the blackfish
which was a terrible idea.
You can't reason with the blackfish Jaime
still tried he's all about trying to keep
his word his honor because everybody says
that he has none, because he's the Kingslayer.
It's been this long think of all he's been
through he's still in the minds of people
like the blackfish just the Kingslayer with
no honor.
What does the word of a Kingslayer mean it
means zero.
You have no honor really have no intention
of saving a man's life's watch in countries
with me on.
I want to see you and post measure of value
I point so that bugs the hell out of Jaime
he is trying to be honorable he wants to do
good things, but he's forced to do the will
of Cersei for now.
So when you start thinking about his reaction
to Cersei at the end of the season slowly
becoming more and more afraid of for the things
that she's willing to do the horrified look
on his face when he sees the great septa blow
up now at this point in the story the TV shows
change the book plot for these characters
quite a bit.
Jaime is not King's Landing to witness this
he's already sworn off Cersei at this point
in the books they haven't had sex since they
did in the septa over Joffrey's dead body
which was traumatic enough, but that was basically
the last time they were ever together as man
and woman after that Jaime affectively abandoned
her, at least emotionally.
So it seems like the show is been teasing
is that Cersei is slowly going mad Queen and
that history will repeat itself for Jaime
he will realize that she needs to be stopped
before she can kill everyone and he will become
the Queenslayer just like he was the Kingslayer
on all
but then you say the Valonqar prophecy is
all about the little brother Tyrion's her
little brother.
But one of the really important hidden points
is that even though there twins Cersei was
born first.
So even though there for the same time Jaime
is the younger brother by a couple minutes.
So by the prophecy he can still be the Valonqar
and what it twist for his character that would
be it would totally be in keeping with the
ark that he is on an even better example is
when he's talking to Walter Frey and Walter
Frey is just chuckling at the idea that they're
both king slayers everybody hates them in
this is such a wonderful thing like there's
so awesome that they have this in common and
Jaime recoils in disgust at the idea that
they share anything in common daily on now
to things like this with you know what it's
like to have them gravel so faces and snigger
behind our backs way to not do it then, is
a mountainous thing and I know a lot of people
would still like to see Tyrion kills Cersei,
but it also seems just like Jaime Tyrion has
been growing up himself to he hasn't been
whoring is much he has been getting drunk
as much we still see him drinking, but we
don't see him get blackout drunk and now that
he's hand of the queen to Daenerys he is so
much responsibility he does is to go into
hardcore analytical mode with various to plan
what they're going to be doing and how they're
going to win the iron throne get rid of Cersei,
but through all the craziness in Marine when
he was trying to hold the city together while
Daenerys was away, it seemed like he really
cared about the people, so even though he
does want to get rid of Cersei he does want
to just kill everybody on site.
So he is not the same Tyrion of this moment
here.
This actually this line here where he says
your joy will turn to ash in your mouth that
was from season two episode eight so that
such a long time ago.
So you guys can let me know who do you think
the Valonqar is and do you think that the
TV show is going to do that but there are
a couple alternate Valonqar prophecy theories
just because little brother could be a more
broad description of a little brother to someone
else, not necessarily Cersei's little brother.
So even though I do think that is talking
about Jaime they could be talking about Aegon
Targaryen from the books they could be talking
about Gantry who is one of the younger brothers
of the other Bastard to Robert for at the
end but it also you know surprised twist valyrian
is gender-neutral when it comes to pronouns
so little brother could just mean little sibling
as an little sister as well like Daenerys,
but I'd I don't see Daenerys like throttling
Cersei that would actually be a pretty funny
site because Daenerys is pretty small and
speaking of size difference the a little brother.
Even though I don't think this is the case
Sandor click gain the hound is the little
brother so that would actually be a little
bit more fun to see him throttle Cersei Jaime
still seems like the best pick.
But there couple other fun alternatives, so
let me know who is your alternate picks who
do you think would have the most satisfying
time killing Cersei and if you want to request
another theory or prophecy video for me.
Just let me know in the comments really that's
what the off season is for two we wait for
to come back talk about all the crazy prophecies
and theories, but I will say congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Andrew Wright
you and HBO now gift certificate.
So be sure to private message me on the back
and my channel so I can get your contact details.
Sophie Turner was talking about how to not
all of the main characters are going to make
it out of season seven alive so my next game
of thrones bonus video is probably going to
be death predictions are the most likely candidates
all the way down to least likely like of the
body of main characters they could kill off
in season seven little fingers close to the
top of the list bottom of the list would be
people like Daenerys Jon Snow, so I'll do
bonus video for that next Sunday later tonight.
There's a fast and furious trailer posting
will do a video for that and and The Walking
Dead finale.
So whole bunch of stuff happening it's gonna
be a lot of fun while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to rewatch that
season seven teaser they drop you can click
here to rewatch those.
Spider-Man homecoming trailer's you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!